tu es et la france l'a toujours respecté
ce départ est un choc
c'est un signal d'alarmé historique qui
doit retentir dans chacun de nos pays
être entendu par l'europe toute entière
et nous faire réfléchir
car en effet pour la première fois en 70
ans un pays quitte l'union européenne je
ne veux pas revenir ce soir sur les
raisons de ce vote et ce n'est
d'ailleurs pas ma place ou mon rôle et
je me souviens combien la campagne de
2016 a été faite de mensonges
d'exagération de simplification de
chèques qu'on a promis et qui
n'arriveront jamais il faut là aussi à
chaque instant nous souvenir de ce à
quoi le mensonge peut conduire dans nos
démocraties
mais nous devons aussi pour nous même en
tirer très concrètement les leçons en
effet je crois très profondément que ce
break site est possible a été possible
et rentre en vigueur dans quelques
heures
parce que nous avons fait de l'europe
trop souvent un bouc émissaire de nos
propres difficultés parce qu'aussi nous
n'avons pas assez changé notre europe
plus que jamais nous avons besoin
d'europe soyons lucides face à la chine
aux états unis pour défendre nos
intérêts nous avons besoin de plus
d'europe pour réussir la transition
climatique nous avons besoin de le faire
au niveau européen pour réussir à
nourrir pour réussir à faire face aux
grandes transformations migratoire
digital technologique nous avons besoin
de plus d'europe et donc je vous
mentirais ce soir à vous dire que
l'avenir de notre pays pourrait se bâtir
dans moins d'europe ou un retrait mais
je suis conscient que l'europe ne pourra
continuer d'avancer que si nous la
réforme on en profondeur pour la rendre
plus souveraine plus démocratique plus
proche de nos concitoyens est donc plus
simple aussi dans son quotidien et que
nous réussissions à rebâtir un projet
européen plus clair pour vous toutes et
tous au fond un projet
ou le désir de quitter l'europe ne sera
plus la réponse aux difficultés
d'aujourd'hui car je pense que c'est une
mauvaise réponse
alors le break site a été l'objet de
beaucoup d'approximations et
d'exagération et je veux ce soir vous
dire quelles seront les prochaines
étapes et les conséquences concrètes
pour vous demain de manière très
pratique
rien ne changera dans nos relations avec
le royaume uni
durant toute l'année 2020
nous vivrons ce qu'on appelle une
période de transition c'est à dire qu'on
pourra voyager exporté commercer et chez
exactement comme avant vous ne vous
réveillerez pas demain matin avec des
règles différentes pour votre quotidien
il y aura un changement
il est institutionnel c'est que dès
demain matin le royaume uni ne
participera plus aux décisions
européennes
pour la france cela signifie que cinq
députés supplémentaires siègeront
désormais au parlement européen ils
remplaceront certains des députés
britanniques qui viennent de quitter ce
parlement je veux aussi dire à nos
concitoyens français vivant au
royaume-uni que leurs droits seront
maintenus préserver défendu qu'ils le
sont et que nous avons garanti dans
cette période de transition évidemment
toutes les règles qui leur permette de
continuer leur vie normale leur activité
je veux aussi dire à tous les
britanniques qui vivent en france
parfois depuis tentes et tant d'années
que là aussi demain matin les choses ne
changeront pas pour eux ils sont en
france chez eux ils le sont aujourd'hui
ils le seront demain il y aura
malheureusement quelques conséquences
très pratique il ne serons plus citoyens
européens et pour ceux qui n'ont pas
demandé la citoyenneté française ils
n'auront le pourrons plus par exemple
faire partie des listes aux prochaines
élections municipales
mais ses conséquences sont très réduites
ensuite il nous faut préparer la
relation future
en effet nous devons bâtir avec le
royaume uni
notre relation de demain
tout l'objet de la négociation qui va
commencer et pour cette négociation nous
resterons unis à 27
nous aurons un négociateur et je suis
profondément attaché à ce que durant
cette négociation nos intérêts
c'est-à-dire les intérêts de notre
pêcheur de nos agriculteurs de nos
industriels de nos chercheurs de nos
travailleurs de nos étudiants soient
maintenues mais il y aura une règle
simple
ce partenariat que nous allons bâtir
avec le royaume uni
c'est un partenariat que je souhaite le
plus proche possible le plus solide le
plus durable mais ce ne sera pas la même
chose que la relation que nous
connaissons depuis quelques décennies on
ne peut pas être à la fois dedans et
dehors le peuple britannique a choisi de
quitter l'union européenne il n'aura
plus les mêmes devoirs
il n'aura donc plus les mêmes droits
ainsi durant les prochains mois nous
aurons à négocier
ce nouveau partenariat je le veux fort
mais je le veux aussi exigeant car je
veux vous protégez vous défendre
protéger l'unité de notre europe qui est
indispensable néanmoins au delà de cette
relation future entre la france et le
royaume uni
c'est une histoire longue fait 202
liberté de courage de combat que nous
avons en partage et je ne les oublie pas
non plus c'est pourquoi notre relation
bilatérale continuera à être forte
nous célébrerons le 18 juin prochain le
quatrième le 80e anniversaire de l'appel
du général de gaulle à londres
et les français savent ce qu'ils doivent
au peuple britannique et ne l'oublieront
jamais
c'est pourquoi en matière de défense de
sciences ou de culture nous continuerons
d'avoir des liens forts bilatéraux et je
continuerai de défendre je me rendrait
prochainement au royaume uni pour les
entretenir et les renforcer voilà mes
chers compatriotes ce que ce soir en
quelques mots je voulais vous dire sur
ce qui ne changera pas demain pour
éviter les angoisses et inutile
mais sur ce qui va changer en profondeur
dans notre europe car un pays vient de
manière très concrète de décider de nous
quitter
et à minuit nous quittera de manière
effective
c'est un jour triste ne nous le cachons
pas mais c'est un jour aussi qui doit
nous conduire à procéder différemment à
bâtir avec plus de détermination encore
une union européenne puissante efficace
et qui parviennent à vous convaincre
davantage et à retrouver le fil de cette
histoire qui fait de l'union européenne
une aventure unique est à mes yeux
irremplaçable vive l'amitié entre
royaume uni et la france vive l'europe
vive la république et vive la france